boa noite é meu nome eu iria eles o
pediatra
sou professor aqui da fag e primeiro
quero agradecer esse convite por
participar aqui do texas foi realmente
uma emoção muito grande e eu resolvi
dividir com vocês um pouco da
experiência que eu tenho em sala de aula
porque isso é algo que eu passo muito
para os alunos
então eu resolvi contar pra vocês sobre
pediatria e o que aconteceu na minha
vida pra que ela entrasse na minha vida
então isso eu passo para os alunos no
meu primeiro dia de aula pra mostrar pra
eles que às vezes as nossas escolhas
aparecem às vezes nem escolha que a
gente faz é a vida que faz pra gente
então inicialmente eu queria falar
porque pediatria seria uma especialidade
que eu jamais faria na minha vida
acredito que alguns de vocês aqui já tem
11 filhos e bom isso aqui né é assim em
casa você imaginou um consultório de
pediatria é choro 24 horas eu falo a
gente veste um jaleco e parece que é uma
entidade do mal que tá personificando
ali no consultório
então é choro que não acaba mais e se
está escrevendo e é criança batendo na
caneta e puxando o fio do computador e
pega seu carinho e pega o hospital então
enfim na faculdade quando estava a única
certeza que eu tinha na minha vida era
que pediatria eu jamais faria e durante
os dois últimos anos de medicina a gente
chama ele de internato então são anos
que a gente realmente a profunda naquela
área e vivenciar tudo então eu estava
nesse internato de pediatria e
justamente por causa dessa vivência com
as crianças eu acabava levando o
brinquedo e fazia bichinho e pegava
criança no colo para ver se elas paravam
de chorar um pouco ea professora falava
assim pra mim não se ele acha que tem
jeito de pedir ata logo deus me livre
jamais faria pediatria na minha vida
qualquer coisa né não sei o que eu quero
fazer mas pediatria ou não faz
enfim ela tá bom é só uma idéia
mas de acabei a faculdade continuei sem
saber o que eu queria fazer
essa certeza que eu tinha então em 2008
né
recém formada eu acho assim que o
recém-formado às vezes é tem aquela
idéia utópica é de quanto terminando a
medicina e a ideia que eu tinha era o
seguinte vou trabalhar demais então em
2009 né no final do ano vou tá lá
fazendo uma residência nos melhores
hospitais do país
vou ter meu ea ti meu jatinho e
piccinini mansão e viagens mil nem tão e
isso eu acho que eles trazem isso até
hoje né eles realmente acham que
terminando vai ser assim
infelizmente em 2009 não foi isso que
aconteceu comigo tá essa aqui gente já
ouviu até me espantei quando eu achei na
internet né
comecei a procurar os locais para fazer
os plantões como acontece com a maioria
dos alunos e foi trabalhar lá em são
caetano de odivelas e essa aqui é a foto
do hospital que eu trabalhava na eu
tirava plantão nesse hospital eu dividi
a gente dividiu a semana com os colegas
então eu tirava o final de semana o
plantão de 48 horas chegava no sábado de
manhã e sai ano saiu na segunda de manhã
graças a deus não estava nesse dia que
estava apedrejando o hospital mas era lá
e isso aqui realmente a cidade onde eu
ficava tá então a cidade termina ali na
pata mesmo na selva tem um riozinho ea
gente lá né
incrivelmente eu falo assim a gente
acredita e muita coisa durante a
faculdade e uma das coisas né que eu até
tenho falou assim eu deveria ter
percebido porque quando eu fui negociar
salário a com o prefeito ao secretário
de saúde
ele tinha me prometido acho que os 30
mil reais por mês
né eu deveria ter pensado assim gente se
eu tô indo conversar que com efeito né
no celta que naquela época era o
carrinho que eu tinha e ele vem de
bicicleta né alguma coisa tá errado né
ele me falar que nenhum médico trabalha
aqui peguei a 30 mil reais por mês né
mas achei o máximo não foi nosso não tem
ninguém querendo eu né
ninguém queria tão lá fui eu para os
meus plantões em isla de 48 horas
é claro que eu não recebi nada né
então trabalhei lá em outubro novembro é
todo mês a mesma coisa não
agora não agora neste mês não esse mês
não em dezembro né eu lembro que eu
estava lá num desses plantões de final
de semana e o pessoal da assistente
social os agentes comunitários foram
fazer visitas nas casas nem como é de
costume nos postos de saúde e eles
chegaram numa casa né que estava pegando
fogo escutaram crianças chorando e era
um bebezinho de quatro meses e um outro
bebezinho de um ano levaram lá pro
hospital que eu trabalhava
graças a deus nenhuma das crianças
tinham sofrido nada mais grave não tinha
inalado fumaça nem nada mas eles falaram
assim olha a doutora é como vocês viram
o tamanho da cidade aqui é a gente vai
liberar essas crianças para adoção na
segunda-feira e e porque assim a mãe já
tinha 11 filhos era prostituta os outros
filhos ela prostituir para comprar droga
prostituir as filhas dela então assim
não tem condição ela vai tendo filho
atrás do outro e esses dois a gente já
vai tirar para liberar
só que a cidade é muito pequena não tem
local onde ficar essas crianças ea gente
até ofereceu só que todo mundo só quer
ficar com o bebê de quatro meses porque
eram dois índios vizinhos
ninguém quer ficar com a criança de um
ano que é mais escura é um pouquinho
mais escura
nem eu nossa é difícil né ela falou ea
gente até tentou procurar tio tia
ninguém também eles falaram que não iam
ficar porque já cuidava dos outros enfim
aí talvez em nossa não vou deixar nem as
crianças assim aí liguei pra minha mãe a
mãe é o seguinte aconteceu isso assim
que eu quero que o pessoal do conselho
quer saber se tem como a gente ficar com
as crianças um pouco até eles acharem
algum familiar que queira eles vão atrás
no concelho tem todo esse cuidado de
procurar algum parentesco e minha mãe
ser assim pra mim nós trielli mais uma
semana para o natal né tá pode trazer eu
vou falar não tem nem como então na
segunda feira cheguei eu
duas crianças um bebê de quatro meses
onde um ano conselheira tutelar
assistente social enfim uma galera no
carro né aí chegamos lá pra cá vou ligar
pra minha professora né pra aquela lá
que falava que eu tinha que fazer
pediátrica olha a professora aconteceu
isso assim eu posso levar as crianças
para a senhora examinar elas e talvez
leve e chegou a todo mundo de novo né
aí ela fez alguns exames tudo graças a
deus tudo bem que as crianças a
franciele por que você não faz pediatria
né eu já tinha falado isso eu acho que
tem tudo a ver com o teu deus menino
professora não quem isso é só porque eu
peguei duas crianças assim todo mundo
faz isso não plantando e você não tem
banda mirim
nessa acontece com a gente no plantão
ela torneio é este que se tem que sempre
pensar não nada a ver
enfim peguei as crianças e tal nem levei
para casa e como eu não tinha recebido
durante esses três meses eu pensei assim
a vou lá para o sul trabalhar é procurar
outro lugar conhecer um pouco de frio né
era lá em belém gente tão bem quente né
é só o ano inteiro e comecei a procurar
um local aqui consegui os plantões em
foz
só que mais ou menos uma semana antes de
embarcar o mais velho de um ano teve uma
crise de asma horrível a pior crise de
asma que até hoje como pediatra eu vi na
minha vida que eu nunca vi uma que é tão
ruim como a dele e eu já estava
acostumado é quando você sai da
faculdade sabe manejar é o geral tirar
de crise tudo e eu já estava acostumada
tirar pessoa adultos e crianças de crise
e eu não tirei ele foi o único que eu
não consegui tirar da crise de asma e
ele foi para a uti e ver isso né ver
aquela criança que está com você né você
não conseguir fazer nada por ela isso me
marcou demais
então pensei ah eu acho que a pediatria
mesmo eu acho que esse era o sinal que
eu estava esperando pra achar minha
especialidade
então isso geralmente eu conto para os
meus alunos porque eu espero de verdade
que quando
eles forem escolher a especialidade da
vida deles que vai ganhar a vida deles
eles não escolheram baseada em status no
dinheiro que eles podem ganhar em
qualquer outro motivo
mas realmente naquilo que vai fazer
diferença pra eles como vi na vida como
pessoa e como profissional
hoje em dia eu não escolheria nenhuma
outra especialidade
nem sei que existem outras
especialidades realmente você até
consegue ganhar mais mas eu sei que eu
não seria feliz com nenhuma outra e isso
eu passo para eles que realmente vocês
consigam ter essa felicidade de escolher
aquilo que vai ser bom não só para vocês
né mas para os outros também não
consegui o meu jatinho não conseguiu meu
iate não tenho a minha mansão com
piscina mas eu tenho as duas coisas
legais é a cinco coisas mais importantes
que eu poderia querer esse que tá em
pezinho mais moreninho é o de um ano tá
o que na época foi para a uti
o outro é o uso de quatro meses e na
residência em pediatria acabei ganhando
tá
acabei me casando com um pediatra né ele
era o meu r 2
e ele também fez residência lá no acre
né e quando eu contei para ele a
história
ele falou assim anúncio não eu também
sempre quis trazer um indiozinho tava
tem de um monte e tal ea gente pensou em
ficar nos dois né
até então achava que eu não podia ter
filhos nem fui tendo acabou que eu podia
ter e não parei desde então
então hoje em dia já estou com cinco as
que não terei mais por enquanto mas é
isso que eu quero deixar né de mensagem
no texas
é isso que eu quero passar isso que eu
passo para os meus alunos que realmente
a escolha de vocês seja com essa
consciência né não só na medicina mas
acho que em qualquer profissão que
qualquer um tenha né que seja aquilo que
realmente faz diferença pra você e para
os outros não é dinheiro não é status
nada disso traz a felicidade é aquilo
que realmente importa então não fui eu
que escolhi a pediatria
realmente a pediatria que me escolheu é
isso boa noite
[Aplausos]